travis scott's astroworld festival was
supposed to be a weekend of celebration
instead it turned into tragedy and chaos
and that left eight people dead our
lauren zima is on the ground in houston
with the very latest kevin i'm standing
in front of a makeshift memorial paying
tribute to those eight victims the
youngest of which was 14 year old john
hilgert meanwhile police have launched a
criminal investigation
i couldn't breathe and then i was
panicking investigators are reviewing
videos that captured the scale of the
chaos
fans rushing through the gates a woman
desperately pleading for the concert to
stop
and this concert goer dancing on an
ambulance i'm honestly just devastated
the rapper and producer's girlfriend
kylie jenner who is pregnant with their
second child was in the audience with
their three-year-old daughter stormy she
said she and travis are broken a source
tells e.t the couple is processing what
happened and trying to make sure
something like this never happens again
so what went wrong well shortly after
travis took the stage around 9 15 the
crowd surged pushing people into the
barricades eventually you just
surrounded by a bunch of people today i
spoke with three concert goers houston
chronicle music critic joey guerra
chomuri da silva who watched two people
die and mark diaz as of this morning
mark's tick tock video showing what was
going on in the middle of the chaos had
more than 11 million views there was a
lot of people there like i can't breathe
i can't breathe but they're staying
there because they want to be close is
probably one of the worst locations
because there was absolutely no exit
path
anywhere near us
people started panicking you know there
were people kind of i think trying to
get
over the rails to the stage there were
people climbing things there's so much
chaos hundreds of people around me were
screaming bloody murder like help help
get us out
there's another video that's gone very
viral of a young woman up on the camera
platform telling the cameraman people
are dying down there people are dying
down there
when you watch that
what was going through your mind
uh i definitely thought that was intense
obviously someone should have helped or
someone should have listened there
should have been plenty of pathways for
security paramedics the police
crowd control
travis scott says he will cover funeral
costs for the victims provide full
refunds for all astroworld attendees and
he's canceled a scheduled performance in
vegas this weekend i could just never
imagine the severity of the situation
even with his apology travis has a
history of concerts getting out of
control
[Applause]
2015 switzerland seemingly encouraging
fans to beat up a concert goer after he
tried to steal travis's shoe get him out
of here
i see you bro
2017 new york egging on a man to jump
from a balcony another fan who fell was
left paralyzed
2017 arkansas the rapper urging security
to let charging fans rush the stage
the netflix dock look mom i can fly
shows travis was later arrested and pled
guilty to reckless conduct he amps up
the crowd absolutely i was expecting
that kind of intense kind of energy
you're here to rage we're here to jump
and party and stuff like that in fact in
2015 gq did a segment called how to rage
with travis scott i always wanted to
make it feel like it was the wwf at the
end of the night
this time in houston travis did hype up
the crowd but also paused his
performance multiple times to help fans
we need somebody to help somebody pass
out right here it's an ambulance in the
crowd
so after 9 15 pm is when many say things
were getting out of hand by 9 38 police
had declared this a mass casualty
incident but travis continued with the
concert at about 9 45 after seeing an
ambulance in the crowd he asked fans to
put two hands up if they were okay
the concert went on for nearly 40 more
minutes after that maybe there was an
encore that he was going to do that
didn't happen you know but yeah it was a
75-minute set which was what it was
originally supposed to be as of this
afternoon nine lawsuits had already been
filed e.t had obtained documents for two
both seeking millions in damages for
alleged gross negligence you cannot just
close when you got 50 000 and over 50
000 individuals okay we have to worry
about riding if they would have made an
announcement at some point early to stop
the show that could have potentially
caused even more injuries possibly even
more deaths there's going to be a big
kind of microscope on him in the way
that he kind of engages fans in how he
kind of controls the crowd when he's on
stage it was just lack of judgment lack
of communication and they need to focus
on what we can do next time to prevent
things like that from happening
you